welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for our
presentation titled basic concepts
and imaging based high throughput
screening and high throughput profiling
assay development
it's my pleasure to introduce you to
joshua harrell
joshua is a cellular and molecular
toxicologist
with the u.s environmental protection
agency center
for copy excuse me computational
toxicology and exposure
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
if any questions should arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q
a box our speaker will address your
questions at the end of the presentation
please join me in welcoming joshua
harrell i'll now turn the presentation
over to him
hello my name is joshua herrell and i'm
a molecular toxicologist at the us epa's
center for computational toxicology and
exposure
i'd like to thank the organizers of the
sbi squared meeting for inviting me to
come give this course
basic concepts in imaging based high
throughput screening
and high throughput profiling assay
development
my pointer
first i'd like to start with a
disclaimer the views expressed in this
presentation are my own
and do not necessarily represent the
views of the u.s environmental
protection agency
nor dimension of trade names nor
products represent endorsement for use
first i'd like to state the objectives
for this session
in this session we will explore the
basic concepts in imaging based high
throughput screening
and high throughput profiling assay
development to those who are new to this
area of science
we will provide examples from a variety
of hcs assays to contextualize the assad
development process
and we will discuss considerations for
experimental design and methods
for evaluating high content screening
and high throughput profiling assay
performance
on this slide i show a few resources
that may be of use to the people
attending this course
several guidance manuals for high
content screening assay development
as well as some reviews on the type of
technology we
will be discussing today
um i would like to introduce some key
terms to get us started
the first term is high throughput
screening high throughput screening
refers to large-scale experiments or
combinations of robotic automation
liquid handling devices instruments for
detecting assay specific outputs
and data processing and analysis
pipelines come together
and are used to evaluate the biological
effects of hundreds to thousands of
agents whether they be chemicals
si rnas or others in parallel
high content screening is a high through
is a high throughput screening approach
that combines automated fluorescence
microscopy
and quantitative image analysis to
assess the biological activity of test
agents on a specific process
or cellular function at the level of the
single cell
or single organism uh synonymous with
high content screening or high content
analysis high content imaging human
cytometry
but hcs is typically used to denote
higher throughput
high content profiling is different from
high content screening
high content profiling is a hts approach
that combines automated fluorescent
microscopy
and quantitative image analysis to
assess the biological activity of test
agents
by measuring a very large variety of
features
at the individual cell level a feature
being a property of a cell or an
organism
that is measured using this quantitative
microscopy approach
so screening is a distinct strategy from
profiling
although both hcs and htp both involve
large-scale high-throughput imaging
experiments
the goals differ in screening the
researcher aims to measure one or more
phenotypes that are visually discernible
and choose a subset of hits for further
investigation
essay design is based on a priori
knowledge of a biological process of
interest such as a receptor
translocation
or production of reactive oxygen species
while profiling collects a broad
spectrum of measurements designed
that are captured from each sample
unguided by prior knowledge
in order to reveal important differences
and similarities with other samples
screening depends on on a biologist's
expertise
to interrogate a particular phenomenon
whereas profiling takes an unbiased
approach
to grouping samples with a higher
potential to capture
unknown mechanisms of action
so why consider hcs or htp
hts assays can provide information on
the biological activity of test agents
however they provide single low content
readouts
in contrast high content screening hcs
can be used to evaluate many of the same
biological process as a high throughput
screening assay
or provide more detailed information at
the level of the individual cell or
organism
hcs can be used to evaluate cellular
responses that are not amenable to
traditional hcs assays
such as a change in cell morphology or
the movement of proteins within a cell
and the potential applications for hcs
are broad
shown here in the box at the bottom of
the slide are just a variety of
different applications
for which hcs assays have been developed
including
protein translocation cell surface
receptor activation
cell viability apoptosis proliferation
and a variety of other biological
processes
so what exactly is a high content
screening system
in its most simplest terms it's a
microscope in a box
hcs systems include many of the same
physical components as traditional
microscopes
there are specialized components in
these instruments to increase imaging
throughput
and they also come equipped with image
analysis software
that allow the users to evaluate the
images in a manner that they see
fit these instruments also typically
become
are coupled with data storage and data
management solutions
uh shown on the left hand side of the
slide is just the configuration of a
standard epifluorescence microscope
whereas variety of different hcs
instrumentations
uh instruments that are available on the
market are shown along the top of this
slide
there's a lot of varieties of high
content imaging systems
such as wide field imagers confocal
imagers
laser scanning cytometers and etc
knowing the components of your hcs
system is key so you can use it
effectively to conduct your studies
for the sake of time i won't spend a lot
of time on the next three slides
but wanted to put forth some information
on the components of an hcs system
uh for those who may want to go back and
review these later
but in short the hcs system is composed
of excitation source such as a lamp
laser led
a set of excitation emission filter sets
a variety of objectives for low and high
magnification imaging
detectors such as digital cameras
a high precision automated stage to
facilitate
movement of the sample and
accurate imaging of individual fields of
view as well as high speed autofocus
mechanisms
there's also a variety of different
optional components of hcs systems
such as environmental chambers liquid
dispensers
and plate handling automation
also for the sake of time i won't spend
a lot of time talking about hcs
microplates today
but uh wanted to refer the folks in the
crowd
uh to this review from trask at all in
2018
uh guidelines for microplate selection
and high content imaging
uh suffice to say that the the format
that's most commonly used
in hcs essays to date have been either
96 or 384 well
formats
so moving away from the actual hardware
and the consumables that are associated
with hcssa
i now like to talk about different steps
in the hcs
assay development workflow
what this flowchart shows are a variety
of different considerations for
developing
for development of an hcs assay and the
question you're actually asking yourself
when you're actually designing these
experiments or designing these assays
you always begin with your problem
formulation what biology
am i interested in are you then move on
to an assay concept
how will i measure that biology of
interest
in terms of cell models you should
consider what cell model you could
potentially use to my to measure your
biology of instrument
biology of interest and again what plate
format should i use that would be most
minimal to my system once i have my
assay concept what reagents and probes
could i use to visualize that biology
what's the dynamic range of the response
values that i should expect
when evaluating a particular collection
of reagents or probes
and what exposure conditions should i be
using how will i actually deliver the
test agents to my culture system
and when should i measure the biology of
interest and finally
when should how will i evaluate assay
performance in the context of my essay
to show that it's working and i state
here that even though these
these steps in the process or the
thought process of designing hcs
experiments are depicted as a linear
sequence
that's not always the case uh there's a
lot of interplay
between these different uh questions you
may ask yourself
but they all tend to point back to the
central question of
measuring the biology that you're
actually interested in
so we'll start with the problem problem
formulation when developing an hcs
assay you should begin by asking what is
that biological process of
interest what are the characteristics of
that biological process of interest
and what could you use to measure what
could you measure
to evaluate the effects of your chemical
or test agents
on this biological process of interest
and overall
what is the goal of your study
in the next few slides i will present
several exam several examples of hcs
assays
used to assess different types of
cellular biology we will use these
assays to illustrate concepts in hcs
assay development
throughout the remainder of the talk the
first example is nuclear receptor
activation
the goal of this type of assay is to
identify either nuclear receptor
activators
or agents that inhibit nuclear receptor
activation
the characteristics of the biological
system is that
the system requires that the receptor to
be expressed and functional
and that the appropriate stimulus is
required to actually activate the
receptor
this can be binding of a ligand
post-translational modification or
dissociation from a chaperone
this activation results in either the
translocation within the cell which is
the focus of this particular assay we'll
discuss
as what or association or dissociation
from a binding partner
some type of post-translational
modification on the
on the part of the nuclear receptor or
transcription or translation of a
regulated gene product
shown over here on the right side of the
slide
is a diagram of constitutive anderstein
receptor
of signaling pathway which is the
subject of
my kodiak at all 2019
and basically what we're showing here is
the assay concept for this nuclear
receptor activation assay
uh in the absence of ligand which
activates the receptor
the receptor is sequestered to the
cytosol so you can see the
the yellow labeling of the actual
receptor outside of the
blue label nuclei within the control
condition
addition of its ligand results in
nuclear receptor activation
and then translocation of that protein
to the nucleus
and you can see the pattern of the
fluorescent intensity changes
uh in response to that stimulus and that
is what you want to measure
or evaluate using your high content
screening assay
the second example is oxidative stress
and apoptosis
the goals of this type of assay are to
identify chemicals that produce
oxidative stress and cause apoptosis or
alternatively could be
the identification identification of
chemicals that reduce oxidative stress
and prevent apoptosis depends on which
mode you want to design your assay to
actually
measure the characteristics of this
biology
is oxidative stress resulting from
increased intracellular production of
reactive oxygen species
or decreased levels of endogenous
antioxidant molecules
this oxidative stress can lead to
apoptosis via cleavage of procas base 3
to activate a caspase-3 and cleavage of
parp
by this activated caspase-3 which is
what's shown over here on the diagram
on the right side of the slide and the
hallmarks of apoptosis that you may want
to measure
using a high content screening type
assay could include
reduction in nucleus size some type of
nucleus fragmentation
a loss of plasma membrane integrity
using a cell impermeable dye
or alternatively alternatively some type
of
caspase reagent cleav a cast page
caspase cleavage reagent that when uh
cleaved by an activated caspase actually
redu releases some type of fluorescent
signal
the third example of an hcs assay we
will consider today is a steatosis assay
for
lipid accumulation the goals of this
type of assay are to identify chemicals
that either cause steatosis
or alternatively may be protective
against statosis
and statosis being the abnormal
retention of lipids
within a cell or an organ this is shown
over here on the right
in h e sections of normal liver versus a
fatty liver
and as you can see the cyto architecture
of these cells changes dramatically in
the fatty liver condition
as shown by these large lipid droplets
that actually accumulate in the cells
this can occur for a variety of reasons
including dietary factors
chemical exposures and also signals from
peripheral tissue
and the accumulation of this
triglyceride fat reflects an impairment
of the normal processes
of synthesis and elimination of
triglycerides
that is shown here in a bio and a
diagram here in the
center of this slide which basically
shows how triglycerides are processed
within the liver now these hallmarks of
statoses include the accumulation of
these lipid droplets which can be seen
in a variety of different in vitro
models
and also production of reactive oxygen
species
and the image in the lower right hand
side of this slide shows how you can
visualize lipid accumulation
using a lipid stain so the control
condition up here is in the upper left
hand corner
of this uh this four panel figure as you
can see there's a variety of different
stimuli
that can cause that can cause increased
lipid accumulation within these cells
and then when when combined with a drug
you can actually see a decrease
in the lipid accumulation that was
caused by addition of a separate agent
so this these lipid spots
that are outside of the nuclear label
or something that can be measured and
quantified using an hcs assay
and the final example we will evaluate
uh in the context of this talk is a
neurotite outgrowth assay
so the goals of this type of assay is to
identify chemicals that can inhibit or
enhance
neurotic outgrowth and what i'm showing
over here on the right side of this
slide
is a human-derived neuronal
cell line after several different
after several snapshots up to 24 hours
in vitro
where you can see the elaboration of
these long processes
extending out from the cell body of
these cells and this is the process of
urine outgrowth
um it involves the the extension of
these long thin processes from the cell
body
and these processes contain a variety of
cytoskeletal proteins
that vary according to the actual type
of the neurite
versus axons or dendrites and these
neurite networks become more complex
over time
but this is something that you can you
can visualize and measure
using immunocytochemistry and high
content imaging
um
so moving on to the next slide um
so the type of biology you're interested
in is going to have a big bearing on the
choice of cell model
of that you want to select for your
particular assay
so the choice of cell models is is
guided by many factors
uh the representative representative
biology which
i've highlighted as the most important
factor but also a variety of
practicalities or practical factors such
as availability
scalability of the cell model of
reproducibility
as far as how consistent you can get the
culture model to perform
as well as ease of use you also need to
consider the growth characteristics of
the cell model
the morphology of the cells potentially
cost
and compatibility with your assay
concept such as
the neuron outgrowth of as i just
mentioned or the lipid accumulation
assay
there's a wide variety of different
types of cell models these can include
cancer cell lines immortalized cell
lines
stem cell derived or induced pluripotent
stem cell lines
also primary cultures
a majority i would say of hcs assays
that have been developed have been on 2d
monoculture type systems such as the one
shiver shown over here on the right side
of the slide
but there's also been some development
in the develop
there's also been some movement in the
development of three-dimensional culture
models such as spheroid models
and methods for imaging those
so the next step in the hcs assay
development is cell model optimization
cell models can require optimization of
many different parameters
these can include the media formulation
the growth atmosphere which keeps your
cells happy
the plate coding or growth substrate
that the cells
are minimal to growth and and
maintenance of the cells
as well as seeding density passage
number uh
and labeling strategy and stressors uh
variability sensitivity and dynamic
range of
hcs measurements can vary for the same
cell type under different growth
conditions
and i've shown that over here an example
over here on the right
where these are primary cortical neurons
grown in either one
particular media type dmem or a
different media type neurobasal a versus
b27
shown on the top is three days in vitro
growth
and shown in the middle here seven days
in vitro you can see that the neurite
fields get much more complex
over time but when you actually apply
the type of quantitative measurements
that are used in a high content
screening sense
to measure either the number of neurons
per field or the total neurite length
associated with these various media
formulations
you can definitely see that the the
formulation has an impact
so i state this just to drive on the
point that you you really need to
evaluate
uh fairly extensively how well
uh your culture is developed and
maintained within the assay window
that you want to use and using the
culture
media and cultural conditions that you
wish to use
here i show another aspect of cell model
optimization specifically geared toward
proliferative cells
so what we're looking at in this
particular slide are two different cell
lines cure ct
and rpe1 and what we've done
is uh conduct a cell tighter uh
seating density by time course
experiment
and the goal of this time course
experiment was to identify an initial
seating density
that would result in a culture that is
not overly confluent
at the time in which you want to make
your sample measurement which is in this
case
at 72 hours and as you can see in each
of these cell types
over time uh since they are
proliferative the number of cells in the
wells actually increases
and increases actually quite
dramatically from
from 24 hours out to 17 hours at a given
seating density
uh here i've shown
side by side the results of a low
initial seating density versus a high
initial seating density for the rpe1
cells
at 72 hours which is our goal for
actually measuring a particular
for measuring features in the cells and
the take-home from this slide is that if
you
seed too high you can end up with overly
confluent cultures
these overly confluent cultures can
result in inaccurate segmentation
of the actual cells that you're
intending to measure and also
obscure the biology of interest that's
illustrated down here along the bottom
uh for showing these different uh cell
body segmentation masks for both low
seeding density and the high seeding
density
conditions and as you can see here in
the high seating density condition
you start to lose the fidelity of the
individual cell tracing
because the cells are just so tightly
packed together whereas in the lower
density
you actually get very accurate
segmentation and it's also worth noting
that this
the cells in these two different
conditions actually look very
quite different from one another which
if you're interested in a morphological
endpoint that's affected in these cells
it's very important to understand that
relationship regarding how your
morphology may change
based as a function of seating density
now i want to pivot away from talking
about cell model optimization towards a
discussion of hcs essay concepts
so hcs assays are based on three things
the use of fluorescent reagents and
probes the identification of labeled
objects
and measuring fluorescent intensities
shapes and spatial relationships
between objects and or pixels in hcs the
essay concept can be designed to provide
intuitive measurements of the biology of
interest
listed here in this table are four
example assay
formats and what you may want to measure
within each of these assays so for
nuclear receptor activation
you may want to measure the ratio of
fluorescent intensity inside versus
outside the nucleus
for apoptosis you can measure nucleus
area versus nucleus shape
or perhaps the percent of
caspase-positive cells
for stay optosis you can measure the
number of lipid droplets per cell
or for nurity outgrowth the total
neurotic length per neuron each of these
representing a type of intuitive
measurement of the biology that you're
interested in
and multiplexing of reagents or diff or
measurement of different features
can provide information on different
aspects of the biology of interest
so what this slide shows are just the
variety of different synthetic
and biological reagents that are
available out on the market to
facilitate high content screening assays
there are fluorescent probes these are
molecules that absorb light
at a specific wavelength and emit light
at a different typically longer
wavelength
some of these probes change their
fluorescent emission properties in
response to a binding event
a chemical reaction or a change in their
immediate environment
which can be leveraged to assess the
biology of interest
there's also small molecules these are
low molecular weight chemicals that bind
to specific proteins or molecules within
a cell
uh some examples of those are endogenous
fluorescence or
conjugated to a fluorescent probe
there are sensor molecules these are
probes that change fluorescent
properties after interaction
with a reactive molecule within the cell
examples of these include
reactive oxygen and nitrogen stress
sensors
as well as voltage sensors and there's
also antibodies which are
immunoglobulins that recognize and bind
to specific antigen
uh antigens um and these antibodies can
be
uh conjugated to a
fluorescent probe such as conjugated
primaries
or you can use primary antibodies in
combination with
fluorescently labeled secondary
antibodies
there's also genetic reagents that can
be used for high content screening
applications
um these heterologous protein constructs
can be incorporated into the genomic dna
or encoded into extranuclear expression
vectors
that are actually present in your cell
type of interest
these are the different varieties of
genetic reagents that have been
engineered for hcs applications
there are fusion proteins which are
created through transcription and
translation
of a sequence that encodes two or more
proteins resulting in the formation of a
single peptide
and for imaging applications these are
designed as a protein of interest with a
fluorescent protein such as gfp or rfp
attached to the n or c terminal end of
the protein of interest
and the expression of these are driven
by the presence of a constitutively
active
constitutively active promoter inserted
into the genetic sequence
alternatively there's the a method known
as fluorotagging
in this method heterologist expression
of a fusion protein
consists of the protein of interest and
an enzyme that reacts with a particular
class of fluorescent probes
this results in a fluorescent labeled
fusion protein
but also provides flexibility regarding
the wavelength of the fluorescent probe
you can incorporate into this type of
system
there's also fluorescent reporter
systems so in these
particular systems heterologous
expression of the fluorescent protein
is driven by the activation of a
promoter sequence
as opposed to being constitutively
driven within the cell
and this is used to detect activation of
intracellular signaling pathway
by endogenous proteins often
when conducting hcs assays it's
desirable to multiplex different
fluorescent probes
in order to evaluate different aspects
of the biology of interest
however care must be taken during the
multiplexing of probes to minimize the
crosstalk
across those fluorescent channels what
i've shown here in the middle of this
slide are the excitation and mission
spectrums
for various combinations of fluorophores
uh
if you focus here on the dappy plus
alexa 48
diagram what you can see is the
excitation spectra
of dappy in the blue dotted line which
is excited by a laser
and the emission spectra which is the
field in curve
in the darker blue the filter set that's
used is able to sample the wavelength of
emitted light
from the dappy stain within the solid
blue band
when we add the alexa 48 antibody our
reagent
you can see here the excitation spectra
in the teal
for this particular reagent and the
laser that's exciting
and the the emission filter that allows
you to uh
sample the particular wavelength of
light uh within this
this solid teal distribution here
so you can consider that that these two
reagents are compatible with one another
because the the excitation wavelengths
don't overlap and you're able to
to a fair extent separate the emission
spectra of these two
when you try to multiplex a third probe
which is shown over here on the right
side of the slide
what i've shown here in the a488 plus
a541
is a combination that's incompatible and
this is due to the fact that the
excitation and emission wavelengths of
these two floor probes
are too close together in terms of the
wavelength spectra and you won't be able
to separate the signal from the two
uh using a the same excitation
or emission of the same excitation
sources or emission filters
in contrast if you were to substitute
a541
for a568 then you do get a favorable
excitation emission profile
which allows you to confidently
multiplex these reagents
and and measure the signal and separate
the signal that is emitted from each
general rules of thumb for multiplex and
fluorescent probes is that targets with
higher signal
should be imaged in the lower
wavelengths than targets with lower
signals so the the more intense signals
should be imaged down at the lower end
of the spectra
and you should also routinely evaluate
the crosstalk between channels
using singleplex labeling and evaluation
of off-channel images
during your optimization optimization
process
uh the next step and conduct a
conducting of
hcs assay after you've done the image
acquisition or
the labeling of your sample with the
fluorescent probes in the image
acquisition
is called segmentation and this is the
separate
separation of signal from background uh
so what i'm showing
here is a pixel intensity distribution
uh for a particular image and there are
areas of this pixel intensity
distribution which are associated with
background which have very low pixel
intensities and these would be the black
pixels
shown within this hertz labeled image
here and then
the brighter objects or the brighter
pixels in this image are
related to the foreground objects and so
what the hcs imaging algorithms can do
is actually
separate these bright objects on a dark
background
and trace them as a segment them which
is
tracing as individual objects i've shown
this here for two examples
uh the herched nucleus stain and nucleus
trace
as well as using segmentation to
identify uh uh particular lipid spots
in a nile red stain of uh of a hep rg
hyperrg cell that's been treated with
lipid once these objects have been
identified then their properties and
associations with other objects can be
measured
as endpoints in an hcs assay
so back to our different examples of the
hcs assays we're considering
this assay concept for apoptosis the
cell model that we're speaking about
here is the mcf7
dental carcinoma model the biology of
interest is in apoptosis
the visualization approach is this caffe
caspase cleavage
dvd peptide uh the thermo fisher selamat
caspase 37 or
alternatively the incucite caspase-37
reagent
and the nucleus counter stain which is
herch 33342
for the image analysis approach we want
to identify the nuclei
and select the nuclei of interest and
then measure the caspase-37 intensity
within the nucleus mask
scoring each cell as a responder or a
non-responder
based on the intensity of the caspase
label within each of these masks
then our intuitive output from this
particular hcs assay
is the percentage of caspase-positive
cells
um this just visualizes some of the
results from this type of assay
uh here we're showing three different
images dmso treated uh
baseline uh star sporing treated cells
which uh produce a partial response in
the cell model at this particular
point in time where you can see some
cells beginning to undergo apoptosis
and showing the compacted nuclear
morphology in the green labeling
and then we see a separate reagent
called ionomycin
which produces a full and uniform
response and this is
a cell death apoptosis response
and basically what we're showing down
here on the
bottom part of these the bottom portion
of this slide are the uh distribution
the cell level distributions
of uh average intensity in this
green fluorescent channel for our dmso
star sporane and automyosin treatments
and what you can see is that the
as these different intensities of
stimulus are applied
that the distribution of fluorescent
signal intensity changes
according from the dmso to this partial
response profile which we see in star
sporting
to this uniform response profile that we
see
with anamycin
and you can use that to actually there's
a couple of different approaches that
you can use to actually calculate a
quantitative endpoint out of that
you can either measure the
well level mean of the caspase intensity
in the green fluorescent channel where
the caspase
reagent is imaged
and the disadvantage of this is you will
not be able to detect any type of rare
events associated
with your apoptotic response may obscure
some of those partial responses
or you could use a percent responder
approach where you actually
score each cell based on the average
intensity of the apopto
apoptotic label within the nuclear mask
and in this you can actually
start to detect some some rare events as
far as
partial responses of your cells to this
apoptotic stimuli
so how do you actually use this percent
responder
type approach you have to determine a
percent responder
gate and this is based on the central
tendency of the control data
plus a multiplier of the variability in
the fluorescent signal you're measuring
for example
uh any cell that has a fluorescent
intensity of of
signaling that's greater than or equal
to the mean plus or minus two standard
deviations of your controls
would be scored as a responder and
anything less than that would be scored
as a non-responder
um and then you can actually see here
how
various multipliers of the control
standard deviation
affects your percent responder outputs
in response to either dmso
ionomyosin in green or star scoring in
blue so this is another type of
optimization that you can do to actually
set your responder gating
for this particular high content
screening assay
here's another assay concept we touched
about earlier in the talk the statosis
assay concept
the cell model here is a differentiated
2d hep rg cultures which contain
a mixed population of both
cholangiocyte-like cells
and hepatocyte-like cells which actually
have different
morphology in terms of their of their
appearance
the biology of interest we're measuring
is lipid accumulation in these cells
and the visualization approach is the
nile red labeling of those lipids with
the nucleus counter stain
in terms of our image analysis approach
we want to identify the label nuclei
select the nuclei of interest based on
the morphology of the hepatocyte-like
cells
which are shown here in green those are
the smaller more compact nuclei
and then define a region of interest
around each cell type
and then identify the lipid droplets
within each region of interest
and the intuitive output that you
achieve from this high content imaging
approach
is the average number of lipid droplets
per hepatocyte-like cell
and thirdly another assay concept
neurite outgrowth
our cell model here are these human
embryonic stem cell derived neural
cultures
our biology of interest is the extension
of neurites from the cell
body and our visualization approach is
beta tubulin
immunocytochemistry with a nucleus
counter stain
as far as our image analysis approach we
want to identify the nuclei as before
and select the nuclei of interest and
use positional information from the
nucleus channel superimposed on the beta
3 tubulin labeling
to identify the cell bodies and
conductor cell counts
and then trace and measure the neurites
in this assay
and the intuitive output here for this
particular assay is neurite lengths
per neuron another critical component of
hcssa design
is the use of controls that allow you to
to evaluate different aspects of assay
performance
listed in this table are a variety of
different control types
such as untreated controls these are
assay wells that do not receive any test
agent
vehicle controls are assay wells that
receive the test agent delivery vehicle
such as dmso but did not receive a test
agent
positive controls or assay wells that
receive a test agent known to produce an
expected effect on an assay
whereas negative controls are the
opposite these are assay wells that
received a treatment that is not
expected to have an effect in an
assay there's also no label control
wells which are assay wells containing
cells
treated or untreated that were not
labeled with the detection reagents
that allow you to evaluate the
background signal that may be emanating
from your biological system
in the absence of the detection reagents
themselves
this is just an example of how assay
controls can be implemented
in untreated versus vehicle to determine
a vehicle tolerance that is at what
concentration
does the delivery vehicle of your test
agents actually affect the assay
this is in the context of a neurite
outgrowth assay
where we actually are tested dmso
concentrations ranging from
0.05 all the way up to 5 and as you can
see in the different uh
morphological measurements of interest
average number of neurites per neuron or
total neurite length
you start to see significant effects at
concentrations of around
1 dmso so for optimization purposes you
would want to use some type of
vehicle concentration that is less than
that so you're not affecting the biology
of your system
um this is an example of a
high content screening experimental
design in 384 well plate format
that incorporates each of the type of
control conditions that we just
discussed
so the no label controls the untreated
vehicle controls
and and also positive and negative
control chemicals in concentration
response as shown in the red and the
blue
we also have a variety of test agents in
this plate design
each upper and lower half of a column
representing a test agent in eight point
concentration response
and what you can do with these types of
data is actually evaluate the
reproducibility
of say potency values you would see
in a high content screening
concentration
response mode type experiment in
particular we're looking here at an
example of cell viability
so here we have the percent percent
responder cells in panel a which
represent the
the magnitude of the cell viability
response
and also the normalized cell count and
each one of these lines represents the
the positive control star of sporing
from each individual assay plate
and as you can see these these
concentration response curves are
virtually
superimposable upon one another which
indicates
you're getting good assay performance
using
these positive controls this positive
control camera
chemical to evaluate that you can also
perform concentration response modeling
to identify a potency associated with
each one of these curves
which is shown over here on the right
side of the slide and as you can see
for each of the plates that were
actually measured in this experiment
this uh this potency estimate is
actually quite consistent
if these values were spread all over
this uh
this plot uh you may consider that
or if one value was safe very far offset
from the rest
you may look at that plate as having
poor performance and may actually
consider
perhaps excluding it from your data set
there's also a concept that you need to
characterize for hcs essays known as
dynamic range
so the theoretical dynamic range is the
range of values that could be measured
or calculated for a particular assay
endpoint
for each of the different assay concepts
that we've talked about throughout this
talk
i've listed the endpoint and the
theoretical dynamic range that you could
observe
for each of these for example for
example a percent repo
responder is probably the easiest to
understand uh
the if you're scoring each cell as a
responder non-responder
then the theoretical dynamic range you
can achieve is between zero
response and 100 response uh
likewise lightweight wise for nuclear
receptor activation
if you're considering intensity in a
nucleus uh
the background to the upper limit of
your camera might actually be a
theoretical
dynamic range for this particular assay
in contrast the empirical dynamic range
is the different
difference in values between your
control conditions and the most
efficacious positive control condition
you
you've included in your experiment and
characterizing this empirical dynamic
range
is an important step in evaluating
whether or not your
hcs assay is actually capable of
detecting
biologically meaningful changes that are
based on the biology of the system
you're interrogating
so this is just an example of hcs assay
performance metric
known as the z factor and and basically
what this is is a calculation comparing
the distribution of signal
in both your control condition and your
positive controls
and uh this chart that has been
published by zangetal for quite a while
kind of adds an interpretation to the z
factor ranges that you may observe
when comparing uh your controls versus
treated
positive control can treat it in this
manner
so a z factor of 1 indicates an ideal
assay
whereas a z-factor between 0.5 and 1 is
excellent assay
and just above zero is a marginal assay
uh if it's less than zero then
there's really too much overlap in
between your
your your control signal and your
positive control signal
to discern much of a change at all in
the response you're trying to measure
and this plot over here shows a percent
responder
for cell viability where we've done a z
prime calculation
and shown that the the controls in red
and the star sporting treated cells in
blue have a z
prime of about 0.61 which falls in the
range of a fairly good assay
now i'd like to pivot again from the
topic of hcs assays to the topic of high
throughput profiling assays
in contrast to hcs high throughput
profiling assays or http assays
measure hundreds to thousands of
phenotypic features and the endpoints
reported are not always
intuitive the highly multiplex nature of
htp assays requires a modified approach
for evaluating
assay performance that uses reference
chemicals
and the concept of profile concordance
what i'm showing over here on the left
hand side of this slide
is an example of different phenotypic
features that can be derived from a
phenotypic profiling assay known as cell
painting
so in this particular assay organelles
within this
various organelles within the cell are
labeled with a variety of different
fluoroprobes
the cell is divided into a variety of
different compartments
and that each combination of compartment
versus
a fluorescent channel the
distribution or the the properties of
the fluorescent label
within those different compartments are
measured in a variety of different ways
resulting in a large number
of feature outputs at the level of the
individual cell
these are just some examples of the
types of phenotypes you can observe
using the cell painting assay
with phenotypic reference chemicals
these chemicals
elicit reproducible but distinct
profiles of phenotypical
phenotypic effects and those profiles
may be specific for a particular channel
or organelle
or may affect many of the components of
the cell a good comparator here are the
chemicals along the tops
the top row of this image so each pair
of images is at solvent control versus a
treatment
and what you can see with this
particular chemical berberine chloride
is that the the phenotypic effect that's
induced here
is a change in mitochondrial compactness
so you can actually see the
the mitochondria labeled in red changing
morphology
between the control and the treated in
comparison
over here on the right hand side is what
happens with treatment with the topocyte
in these particular cells
you see a massive cell swelling and
changes in a variety of different
organelle features
as a result of this particular chemical
and the cell painting assay
or other phenotypic profiling assays
like it are designed to
just measure a general change
from the ground state of the cell to a
particular phenotype
without any prior any a priori
expectation
of what that phenotype would actually
look like
um this once individual features are
measured in this type of profiling assay
they can be normalized to vehicle
control
and scale to facilitate comparisons
across features
so so what we're showing in this this
heat map are
uh scaled normalized values for four
test chemicals
test and concentration response uh
rapamycin
ca compound berberine chloride and
topocide
and the the rows are arranged from
lowest concentration highest
concentration
the features that are derived from the
cell painting assay are arranged in
columns
and what you can see is that with the
increasing concentration of these test
chemicals
you see either an increase or decrease
in the effect size for each of the
phenotypic features that is measured
and these these profiles actually look
quite different from each other
across the various chemicals that were
tested in this experiment
this is just an example of a
high-throughput profiling plate design
where a variety of different test
chemicals
the the concentration series shown in
green are arrayed on the plate
along with a variety of phenotypic
reference chemicals
and concentration response a cell
viability control
and concentration response and a large
number of dmso controls
what this configuration the experiment
allows you to do
is actually to objectively evaluate high
throughput
profiling assay performance so what we
have here is a figure that was published
in niffler at all 2020
we're actually showing the phenotypic
profiles for a particular concentration
of these four drugs
across nine different or 12 different
test plates rather
so each row in these heat maps are one
example of an instance where this
chemical was tested
and each row is an independent assay
plate the features are once again
arranged
in columns across this heat map and what
you can see is that across
independent tests of this chemical on
different plates
the profiles that are actually produced
for any particular chemical
are quite similar across the different
acid plates
but also quite different from one
another and
by using this combination of the four of
these drugs
you can see that most of the phenotypic
features that you actually measure as
part of the cell painting assay are
affected
in one way or the other you can take
these profiles and perform a correlation
of the effect size here and actually
show that you're getting very strong
reproducibility
for three of these chemicals using this
particular method
across your different assay plates
berberine chloride this particular
approach didn't work so well
just because the uh the small number of
features
that were that were affected for this
particular drug
um but it's as opposed to using a z
prime calculation
which is focused on a you know a single
endpoint uh you can use this type of
more
uh integrated type of approach to make
sure that the
assay is performing well on each
instance that you run it
uh you can also do concentration
response modeling if the
experiment was performed in in
concentration response mode
and come up with potency estimates for
the threshold for biological effects
that you you can then compare across the
different assay plates in your system
and the hope would be that if your your
assay is functioning well
that the spread on these uh potency
values would be very tight
across your different assay plates so
time is running short for this
presentation but i did want to take one
moment to
touch on machine learning approaches
that could be applied in the context of
hcs
and htp assays so what's shown over here
on the left side of the slide is a
figure from sheeter at all 2018
which basically shows the workflow for
applying machine learning type
approaches
to high throughput profiling data it
begins with uh
a segmentation free analysis where
phenotypic feature profiles are
calculated at the level of the
individual cell
and then profiles for individual uh
chemicals
are calculated based on the the
phenotypic features that are measured at
the cellular level
uh then machine learning approaches are
applied to actually
separate chemicals that look similar to
each other
or different from control which is shown
down here in the bottom
of left-hand side of this slide so what
you can see in the red point cloud in
the boot
blue point cloud are two populations of
treatments who've
uh whose phenotypes have actually
diverged from the control treatment
which is sewn in black and this would be
indi indicative of some type of
biological activity
that is being induced by the chemicals
or the treatments that have been applied
to your cellular system
shown over here on the left right hand
side of the slide
is a particular example from louis all
where he uh that group applied
a method known as support vector
machines
to characterize the
the concentration dependent change in
phenotypes
um away from the control ground state uh
as as a function of concentration index
and in
in a very high level summary what this
uh
method allows you to do is evaluate
phenotypic changes away from your
control state no matter really what they
look like
as a function of concentration but to be
able to model that response
as you would in a concentration response
capacity
similar to any other endpoint that you
may measure which is
conceptualized here in panel b uh an
example of this for
a chemical camp to thicken is shown over
here on the far right of the slide
where they've done basically plotted a
principal component type
plot here showing different phenotypic
groups that are
that are emerging as a function of camp
to thicken dose index
and actually shows the concentration
dependent departure from the control
ground state
in the lower right hand side panel
we don't have much much time to digest
this information
i will say that i believe there are
other presentations as part of this spf
squared education day
which will focus more specifically on
machine learning
in hcs assays
so in summary i'd like to conclude by
saying that high content screaming
assays are powerful tools for
interrogating biology
that high content screening assays can
evaluate many aspects of cellular
biology
that are not amenable to evaluation
using non-imaging based methods
that hcs assay concepts are customizable
to a biology of interest
and provide intuitive outputs of the
biology
there are many interconnected steps in
development of success of an hcs essay
and there's a lot of resources and a lot
of examples
out there that can help you find your
way i'd like to thank all the folks at
epa who contributed to the content of
this presentation
as well as my colleagues at perkin elmer
and at this time i will take
any questions
thank you joshua for that informative
presentation we will now move into the
live q a portion of the presentation and
as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q a box
all right our first question
is when optimizing an
hcs assay what kind of treatment
conditions should you use in the
optimization
steps for image acquisition and image
segmentation
well kaylee uh thank you thank you for
that question and thank you everybody
for attending
um happy to speak to that in some ways
so
the conditions that you should use for
optimizing both the acquisition steps
and the segmentation steps in an assay
really depends on the assay concept
you're trying to use
so there's different rules of thumbs you
can follow for for
instance an assay where you're
interested in measuring the change of
intensity of some type of labeled
object or labeled signal what you want
to use for those
optimization steps are both control
treatments and where you actually see
the the basal state of your test system
as well as a positive control treatment
that would that would
cause what you think to be the most
maximal response you could see in the
system
and then use that both of those image
types in tandem
to actually figure out what type of
image acquisition settings you need to
use to cover
that that dynamic range of that signal
and what the
what segmentation strategies would be
most appropriate for both types of
conditions
great thank you our next question here
is
what are some good qc practices to use
when setting up an
hcs assay yeah so there's quite a few qc
practices
that can be put into play throughout the
hcs assay development workflow
uh some of the most common have to do
with uh actual
uh image adjustment after you've
actually acquired the image such as flat
field corrections and things like that
to make sure that there's no kind of
systematic uh imaging artifact that may
be present in your images
another good see good qc practice that
you can put into play
is uh during the process of image
segmentation you can actually install
uh certain processes within that that
segmentation workflow
that may help you either identify wells
whether you have some type of
dust debris some some type of signal
that's not really associated with your
assay and help you exclude those types
of wells
or otherwise mask out those objects that
you really just don't want to measure
so those are a few good qc practices to
put into place
great thank you and it looks like we
have time for one more question
and this one says how many fields of
view
objects images should i acquire in each
well
um that's a good question and there's
really no easy answer to that it's
really going to depend upon your
particular application
when you're actually building the hcs
assay so
uh things you can do during the
optimization steps to explore that
question is
you know run a few experiments where
you've sampled a varying number of
fields or a varying number of
cells of both in your control and in
your positive control treatments
and see where your the the difference in
your signal actually stabilizes
at what point have you collected enough
fields or enough objects
so that your positive control can easily
be distinguished from your
vehicle control um so so really it's
going to be
an application by application situation
um
you also need to take into account your
your databasing capabilities and your
image storage capabilities
a good rule of thumb is not to collect
more images than you need to answer the
question about the biology
otherwise you're just eating enough
eating up a lot of storage space on the
back end
collecting uh too many images
thank you again joshua and thank you to
the audience for your outstanding
questions
as a final reminder any questions that
were submitted and not answered today by
our speaker
will be addressed and answered via email
and this presentation will be available
for on-demand viewing
in the sbi 2 virtual conference for 12
months
please remember to share it with your
colleagues who might be interested in
today's topic
and don't miss out on our other
presentations on our agenda
thank you participation until next time
goodbye